is the best piece of relationship advice
that you've ever received there's so
much that I could share I think received
is hard I don't think I've received much
good relationships if I'm completely
honest but one thing I was thinking
about when you say a 79-year marriage
like that's really impressive right so
the thing that I think applies to that
is something I called new old and old
new and what I mean by that is when I
meet someone new I try to find an old
connection we have so maybe we grew up
in the same city or maybe maybe of a
friend or a family member that has the
same career like you try and find
something that connects you that's old
but when you're in an old relationship a
relationship that's been 79 years or
like you said your closest friend 40
years going strong I try and look for
something new so if you have an old
relationship look for something new and
if you have a new relationship look for
something old and it allows you to just
create this beautiful bond with someone
darn it Jay Shetty every single time